Coney Island années 1950 la plage la
promenade
je travaille ici sur la baie 7 entrez en caroline
excusez-moi
deux de Jenny ici je suis Jenny je suis pompé
sa fille
voici sa femme est-ce qu'il va être surpris je suis
marqué
merci c'est ce que vous obtenez quand vous
épouser un gangster je dois boire un verre
sais que tu as été un bon allemand cela ne peut pas
être ici en ce moment nous nous attendons à
des orages et tu es mariée à un
homme qui est devenu riche en mettant les pieds des gens
dans du ciment que tu n'as probablement jamais eu  faire un
plat femme n'aime plus aller à la pêche
hein elle a fait comme si elle aimait ça
me mettre sur l'hameçon
j'étais le poisson
tu sais c'est une femme marquée elle ne devrait pas
passer à autre chose
est-ce qu'il t'a embrassé pourquoi es-tu
si échauffé Je vais trouver que
c'est évident que tout s'effondre tu m'as l'
air un peu fou quand il s'agit
d'amour on s'avère souvent être notre
pire ennemi
ne
penses-tu pas que tu es un peu mélodramatique
[Musique]
toi